solo a Star Wars story has arrived in
theaters and it finally answers all
sorts of questions fans have been asking
for decades
like how han and chewie first met how
han really won the Millennium Falcon
from Lando and what really happened
during the infamous Kessel run but for
every long-held Star Wars riddled the
film answer it may have actually posed
even more new questions here's a spoiler
filled look at the biggest unanswered
questions in solo a Star Wars story
what's Kyra hiding when Han is finally
reunited with his long-lost love Kyra it
should be a joyous occasion but it isn't
because Kyra is clearly hiding something
or many things from her one-time
boyfriend the question is what exactly
is she hiding it's telling that when Han
asks her how she got out she says she
never did between her comments about
owing the crimson dawn a major debt and
Tobias Beckett's frequent hints that
Kyra has done unspeakable things
it's clear there's a lot more to her
story but until and unless we get a
sequel it seems we'll just have to
wonder exactly what Kyra had to do to
get off Corellia that has her so
indebted to a guy like Darth Maul
speaking of which
wait Darth Maul probably the most
shocking moment in Solo was the surprise
reveal that Darth Maul was the head
honcho of the evil crimson dawn crime
scene part of the reason it was such a
surprise is that the last time
moviegoers saw Maul he had just been
literally chopped in half in 1999's The
Phantom Menace apparently he got better
something fans of the Star Wars cartoons
already knew in Clone Wars and rebels it
was established that he used the force
to survive as bisecting got some robot
legs and eventually ended his life at a
very brief and poorly thought-out
attempt to get revenge on obi-wan Kenobi
so what a smalls appearance mean for any
possible solo sequels are we going to
see a Throwdown between Maul and Han is
Kyra going to become mauls apprentice we
can't wait to find out what about the
Wookiees after Chewbacca is rescued from
slavery he explains in a heartbreaking
sequence that all the Wookiees were
enslaved and driven from their homeworld
and he's on a quest to find them but
when he does finally meet some of his
fellow wookies after helping them escape
from bondage he just kind of leaves that
opens up all sorts of questions who
exactly are these other wookies fans had
speculated that they
be his wife mala and his son lumpy for a
scene in the 1978 Star Wars Holiday
Special
but since there are no subtitles we
don't actually find out whether or not
they're Chuy's family this tribe or just
some fuzzy randos so where do they go
and what happens to them when shoe Baca
leaves
why does chewy decide to stick with Han
instead of his people what role do the
Wookiees play going forward we've got a
lot of questions about the Wookiees but
so far only Chewie knows the answer and
if he's telling us we sure don't
understand it that's just what happened
to l3 arguably the biggest breakout
character in solo is Lando's first mate
navigator and possible love interest l33
7
so when l3 tragically dies during the
slave uprising she incited it's both
moving and oddly triumphant and then
they take part of her brain and upload
it into the Millennium Falcon with Lando
declaring she's now part of the ship so
that leaves us with a bunch of questions
does this mean l3 is actually in the
Falcon throughout the rest of the Star
Wars series is it possible that at some
point between Solo and a new hope Lando
and the gang are able to extract ultras
consciousness from the Falcon and give
her a body again maybe even a human body
in the form of Lando cyborg partner
Lobot and considering her entire deal
was trying to free droids from
subservience isn't it really unfortunate
that she ends up just being turned into
a mindless tool here's hoping we get l3
back somehow in the future did emphasis
start the rebellion at the end of solo
anthis nest the leader of the so called
outlaw gang that's been dogging Tobias
Beckett throughout the film tells Han
that she's going to use the millions of
credits from the stolen shipment of Ko
axiom to fund a rebellion to fight
against the Empire this bombshell seems
to suggest that emphasis is actually the
founder of the Rebel Alliance but if in
fost did actually start the rebellion
what happened to her could she somehow
be related to Rey and if Han was in on
the ground floor of creating the
rebellion how come this never came up
before like when he later became a rebel
general in Return of the Jedi here's
hoping we get to learn a lot more about
emphasis in the future and speaking of
the future
now what in April of 2018 solo star
Alden Ehrenreich
that he was under contract for three
films and it seems clear that solo is
setting things up for a trilogy or more
with major plot threads around the
crimson dawn Keira and Darth Maul left
dangling not to mention the fate of l3
the Wookiees and the birth of the
rebellion solo seems prepared to fill in
the gaps of everything that happened
between Revenge of the Sith and a new
hope but will solo actually get a sequel
all of it comes down to how much money
solo makes meaning the answer to that
question and all the rest can actually
be found right now in your wallet thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]